now that was I was asking for the Paul
de Leeuw fight I was tryin to get that
fight were you really I mean I just want
to get some big fights he's terrifying
die [ __ ] yeah okay yeah for
about a minute and a half and then then
usually break his will
well his his grappling has always been
his Achilles heel but goddamn that left
hand as a missile yeah that uh lorenz
larkin fight where he really like
knocked him on his feet and he was just
kind of like yeah there but not really
there Paul Daley can do that to anybody
his that left hand he has that to me was
a crate that was one of the most
frustrating ones when he fought Josh
Koscheck and threw that punch afterwards
and he got kicked out of the UFC
basically forever and now you see like
Conor throwing dollies through windows
dailies gotta be going what the [ __ ]
yeah I got kicked out forever for this I
even throw a punch that landed now he's
like I wish I wish I was in it when it
was the entertainment business you know
guys like him though are very
interesting where he's such a specialist
you know he's such a striking specialist
yeah I watched him I watched him kick
box actually because you know Bellator
does those yes those kickboxing and in
May any kick box Fernando Gonzalez I
believe and it was it was he's good he's
really good especially in that
kickboxing right when he knows there's
no takedowns there's yeah there's no
threat of and there's a different
distance there and he's really good at
that kickboxing range you know and
unless you're there to be able to really
threatened threatened with the takedown
he's gonna be on his game one of my
favorite fights of his for forever will
be that fight with Nick Diaz which was
just [ __ ] one round of chaos just
chaos until Nick Diaz overwhelmed them
then but Nick just puts that crazy
triathlon pace on you where you just
can't keep up with them I know it
doesn't give you any break I know
and those guys those guys have both Nick
and Nate have done a very good job of
not being afraid to take some damage let
guys let guys really swarm them and they
do have that cardio but I think they
have that they just have that Stockton
just confidence and almost just like
that I've actually the funny thing is
like me and Michael Johnson have sparred
numerous times where we're kind of like
talking to each other because that's
against mine that was against my nature
like that that cocky braggadocious
talking during a fight type of deal I
mean once again that's
this of of almost an alter-ego almost a
little bit different in my last couple
fights you've seen me be more presents
talking a little bit almost kind of egg
and egging them on like not being afraid
you should just be like business
business business got a fight now it's
like hey man I'm in here you're fighting
you're fighting somebody who's
cognitively here my two feet are planted
firmly on this ground right you're not
only well by the moment I'm a hundred
percent we're in the zone hundred
percent present and in the zone like in
the zone ready to die in they're not
afraid to but also willing to willing to
fight a very smart fight smart sharp
composed missing shots taken taken shots
are taking takedowns when I want to and
need to and not being afraid to to just
fight like an extreme extremely talented
veteran rather than just a vessel of
violence you know yeah a vessel of
violence that's interesting way to put
it
to like to think of yourself as a
professional like doing your best to
execute your skillset in such an extreme
circumstance and how many fights have
you had now 22 how many fights do you
think it took before you felt that
comfortable 17 and that crazy
yeah that's not joking it's it's it's
ridiculous I mean I wonder what now I
know why so many people just they have a
short MMA career and then they're done
yeah it's hard it's hard